this video is sponsored by the online
learning community skillshare the first
1000 people to use the link in the
description will receive a one month
free trial
it was Ava's first day of kindergarten
for the first time she was surrounded by
people her age that she didn't know up
until this point she always knew other
children and adults from her parents and
family introducing them to her and up
until this point she had never really
experienced or understood the concept of
feeling alone Ava sat on a bench on the
edge of the schoolyard playground during
the first morning recess observing the
other children playing with each other
many already friends from preschool
which Ava's parents chose to not have
her attend at first it was nice Ava was
happy to just sit there by herself and
observe but then after a little while a
teacher walked up to Ava and said what
are you doing over here by yourself Ava
go play with the other kids I don't know
anyone though Ava responded matter of
factly that's okay just pick a group and
say hi it's better than being over here
by yourself right
Ava sat there for a moment and then a
strange sensation that she had never
felt before of being separate unnoticed
alone began to set in with the haphazard
willingness only a five-year-old is
capable of Ava got up and went over to a
group of four girls playing by the
swings and said hi I'm Ava
for the rest of the morning Ava played
with the girls on the swings in the
jungle gym then during the recess after
lunch she sat with the same four girls
in the open field next to the playground
then the next day she did the same and
then again the several days after that
by the end of the week Ava found the
four girls to be kind of annoying she
didn't relate to most of what they
talked about and were interested in but
it wasn't horrible it was fine and Ava
didn't want to spend her time during
recess and lunch alone and clicks had
already started to form so Ava just
continued to spend the rest of the
school year with the four girls
several years later in Middle School it
became increasingly normal for kids
Ava's age to regularly hang out outside
of school on the weekends and after
school during the week Ava soon found
herself often being invited over other
kids houses to the mall and to
sleepovers and parties around the same
time Ava began to develop a genuine
interest in spending time outdoors and
in nature she especially loved running
very few of her friends seemed to share
the same level of interest in running or
hiking outside of the school's track and
cross-country meets though most of the
time her friends just wanted to sit
around in a living room or walk around a
mall or eventually in high school drive
around and smoke weed or go to parties
and drink Ava wasn't a particularly big
fan of any of these things but it wasn't
horrible it was fine and Ava hated the
feeling of being alone or excluded on
weekends or after school or Worse
looking like a loner so Ava just did
what everyone else did saying yes to
nearly every invite and reaching out to
her friends to schedule plans anytime
she didn't already have them
during High School Ava began dating her
first boyfriend will they started dating
almost immediately after one of Ava's
best friends began dating one of Will's
friends and introduced them a lot of
Ava's friends were now dating and were
much busier as a result often times when
Ava tried to do something during the
week with them they would be busy with
their boyfriends
and so Ava hurried into a relationship
of her own she didn't have a lot in
common with Will and he was of a
different intellectual interest we can
say but it wasn't horrible it was fine
it was nice showing up to parties with
someone and having double dates and
someone to be with when no one else was
around
it lasted a little over a year until
will broke up with her saying that he
found Ava just too clingy and jealous to
handle then came Kevin then Chris then
Paul a series of mediocre not great but
not terrible relationships each lasting
around a year or two each separated by
mere months of each other each ending
because of infidelity or incompatibility
or both
by the end of Ava's childhood and young
adult life she had rarely spent much
time by herself
she rarely engaged in her own Hobbies or
interests and she rarely focused on her
own life now in adulthood Ava's most
recent long-term relationship with Paul
ended after dedicating herself to it for
two years and now most of Ava's friends
were working full-time most in serious
relationships some married and with
families and Ava too began working
full-time herself the world was suddenly
busier her social life was suddenly
quieter for the first time Ava was
regularly alone
the weekends if she was lucky contained
perhaps one social event her weeknights
were typically quiet and isolated in her
apartment her longtime fear and anxiety
of being alone was now what she fell
asleep next to every night and woke up
next to every morning which she sat
across from at her kitchen table every
day as often as she could Ava saw any
opportunity to do anything weird dinner
parties with people she barely knew
making plans with old friends she barely
liked trying to meet a new guy that
could help take the silence away
soon Ava found herself in another
relationship with a man named CJ one of
the first guys she met and talked to
since Paul they completely hit it off
right away and Ava felt a connection
with CJ unlike any connection she had
felt before in memory
CJ was so funny and sweet and
accommodating
soon they began to spend nearly all
their free time together and the
relationship soon blossomed and became
the best relationship Ava had ever
experienced in memory
As Time passed though things began to
change
CJ became a bit colder a bit more
uncaring a bit less sweet and
accommodating When the Smoke of lust in
the early stages of Love cleared there
wasn't as much there as Ava had
originally thought but Ava couldn't even
imagine returning to An Empty Apartment
an empty bed a sink with dishes that
were only hers and so they continued
dating
whenever the two fought Ava feared the
prospect of CJ breaking up with her or
the relationship being ruined so she
almost always caved and accommodated
CJ's preferences he must have found this
very pleasing because after four years
of dating he proposed
Ava looked down at CJ on his left knee
ring displayed and began to cry
uncertain of which emotions were inside
the tears
a year later they were married
as more time passed CJ's seeming
indifference toward the relationship
quietly slid into a state of inertia Ava
had never felt so alone in her entire
life but she grew accustomed to the
coziness of mediocrity and banality
she never realized just how bad things
were until six years into the marriage
CJ died killed in a car accident caused
by reckless driving
Ava cried for a while but not long after
inside she felt a deep disquieting sense
of relief
for a while she didn't tell anyone about
this feeling until finally during a
session she told her therapist whom she
had been seeing following around the
time of CJ's death
how could I possibly think that about
someone someone I loved Ava revealed to
the therapist my husband dies and I feel
relief
that's actually not necessarily that
uncommon of a feeling in situations like
these grieving in death and losing
people is complicated and it can involve
all sorts of emotions and factors
sometimes relief is one of them a little
bit of guilt is healthy but too much in
this case isn't going to help anyone or
anything what's important is we try to
understand how we got here the therapist
replied Ava sat quietly for a few
moments for a year she had been going to
therapy sessions and thinking about this
it was as if she had been slowly
chiseling away at a lifetime's worth of
stone that she built around her and in
this moment she finally broke through it
her eyes began to water
[Music]
my whole life I've been so afraid of
being alone I just did anything and
everything I could to not be I never
stopped to think about whether something
was good or right I never let things go
or end when I knew they weren't I don't
even really know who I am when I'm not
in the reflection of other people
she paused for another moment and fell
back in the couch she was sitting on I
should just stop trying I shouldn't date
anyone ever again I'm done Ava concluded
the therapist waited a moment then she
said well we don't need the pendulum to
completely swing the other way being
alone isn't the goal there's nothing
wrong with wanting to not be alone with
seeking companionship and love and
active social life and everything else
but how we look for and navigate through
these things is what makes the
difference being motivated by speed
instead of accuracy by fear rather than
intention that is what will create a
life in which maybe you're not alone but
eventually there might not be much of
you at all you have to learn how to be
alone first and then you'll know how to
not be
you're still young there's plenty of
time to get this right
a few weeks later Ava was in her
apartment alone she was doing some
cleaning when one of her friends whom
she was still somewhat close with texted
her the text read Ava Zach and I are
going to a little holiday party thing
this weekend and one of Zach's friends
is looking for a plus one he asked if I
had any friends that might be interested
and I figured I'd see if you were maybe
interested in me introducing you to him
and coming with us he's a great guy no
pressure of course either way we should
do something soon
Ava looked down at her phone screen
she thought for a moment then she began
to type
[Music]
this video was sponsored by skillshare
for many of us it can feel like there's
so much pressure to go a certain way and
do certain things in life with
comparisons and opinions always one
thumb swipe away it's easy to just
recede into the common denominator paths
or a current status quo skillshare is an
online learning community that reminds
us that we don't have to do this we can
go our own way and take control over our
own goals and career paths you've likely
heard that skillshare offers a wide
range of fantastic classes on Creative
skills like writing video production and
web design but skillshare is much more
than that offering tons of classes that
cover the entire process of determining
pursuing building and establishing one's
career and discovering success seven
exercises to uncover your purpose
passion and path by Emma Gannon Emma
discusses how she went from a
traditional full-time career path with
which she was relatively unhappy to
taking control over her life by
strategically and thoughtfully beginning
to build a side project into what has
now become her career a best-selling
author and an award-winning podcaster in
the class Emma discusses the entire
process of doing this from first
principles including defining success
for oneself how to start a side project
grow it manage money and Foster a new
potential career
or if you're someone who's already on
your way whether you want to further
hone in on a skill as a writer video
editor or web designer or simply looking
to improve your time management and
organization skills skillshare of course
has classes that will help you advance
over these hurdles as well as someone
always working to advance their video
production Knowledge Learning from
expert video editors like Jordy
vanderput is incredibly helpful when it
comes to improving on tricky higher
level things like color grading and
animating techniques in Premiere and
after effects no matter where you are or
where you want to go skillshare helps
take the pressure off and lets you start
small go at your own pace and Advance
into a career that fits you the first
1000 people to use the link in the
description will receive a one month
free trial of skillshare
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]